but I'm fascinated by white people who
love getting tattoos of [__] they can't
read you don't know what that says that
could say I'm a dumb [__] and you would
have no idea
I know it's it's obviously means
something but if I ask you to not look
at your forearm and write your name in
Arabic whatever that was you'd be like
can I Google it you have never fact
checked that tattoo never once did you
look at it and be like yo how do you say
my name in Arabic and make sure it lines
up somehow we just let white girls do
that I'm like oh no that's what they do
are you from here she's German oh so
that's a I'm not racist tattoo I got you
Germans they're still apologizing for
that 1938 [__] they gotta constantly let
you know they like Jews I'm surprised
you went [__] Arabic honestly that
might be a little bit anti-semitic and
now that I think about it what does that
show you you sure that's your name you
sure it doesn't say free Palestine you
sure yeah we positive about that